bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour suivre dans un
instant les débats des sénateurs autour
de la loi Sapin 2 des débats qui se
poursuivent et qui ont débuté lundi
alors hier les sénateurs ont parlé de
l'article 13 sur les relations entre les
lobbyes et les pouvoirs publics alors le
texte cherche à instaurer plus de
transparence dans ses relations avec
notamment l'instauration d'un répertoire
numérique de ses représentants d'intérêt
notez qu'hier et bien les sénateurs ont
exclus de ces représentants d'intérêt
les associations d'élu lorsqu'elles
exercent des fonctions en tant
qu'instance de consultation de l'état du
Parlement ou encore des collectivités
local autre modification apporté hier
par le Sénat le fait de confier à la ha
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique le contrôle du pantouflage des
haut fonctionnaires c'est-à-dire le fait
qu'ils aillent travailler dans le privé
je vous rappelle qu'aujourd'hui et bien
cette tâche est confiée à la Commission
de déontologie de la fonction publique
tout de suite donc retour au débat dans
l'hémicycle nous en arrivons à l'article
13 demande de parole de Monsieur Michel
learnc merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur mes chers collègues nous
abordons l'article 13 de ce projet de
loi article qui propose la création d'un
registre des représentants d'intérêts
auprès du gouvernement je souscris à une
telle mesure mais j'ai été sollicité par
l'Association des Maires du morbillan au
sujet de l'inscription d'élus sur ce
registre au côté des représentants
d'intérêt privés cette similitude pose
un véritable problème de principe
puisque les associations de maires sont
guidées par la recherche de l'intérêt
général elles sont par ailleurs
composées de personnes élues au suffrage
universel ce qui constitue une
différence de nature évidente avec
d'autres lobes en outre ces associations
départementales d'élu portent auprès des
pouvoirs publics les préoccupations des
exécutifs élus des collectivités locales
les élus locaux répondent
quotidiennement aux sollicitations des
représentants de l'État pour contribuer
à la réflexion partagée qui doit
présider à l'élaboration des textes
législatif sans ignorer non plus la mise
en œuvre localement des politiques
publiques par ailleurs ces associations
d'élus reconnu d'utilités publiqu sont
déjà contrôlés dans leur gestion et leur
fonctionnement avec mes collègues du
groupe CC nous ne sommes pas opposés aux
nécessaires besoins de transparence bien
au contraire toutefois nous pensons que
la défense de l'intérêt général ne doit
pas être assimilée à celle d'intérêt pur
privé c'est pourquoi nous espérons que
nos débats sur cet article permettront
de l'amender afin d'exclure les
associations d'élus locaux de la liste
concerné merci merci Monsieur le
squarnc
alors nous en arrivons à un amendement
561 rectifié de Monsieur
Colomba moi je suis tout simplement pour
la suppression de ce ce registre qui
sert strictement à rien
très très franchement là encore c'est on
fait on fait de la
fumée franchement est-ce que est-ce que
d'abord une d'une on là-dessus dans la
dans la dans la discussion enfin par
exemple s'agissant des élus en
particulier les élus nationaux alors il
faudrait demander la permission pour
rencontrer g
ENF c'est c'est complètement loufoc bon
et puis voilà et tous ceux qui veulent
corrompre et cetera excusez-moi mais
c'est pas parce que ils seront inscrits
sur un registre qu'ils auront fait des
rapports et cetera que ça changera quoi
que ce soit mais mais franchement il
faut quand même avoir un esprit un peu
curieux pour proposer des choses comme
ça bon encore une fois
c'est faire croire qu'on veut faire
quelque chose alors qu'en fait on fait
rien
quoi bon monsieur Marie monsieur Marie
explication de vote aussi
oui merci monsieur monsieur le Président
euh l'intervention de de notre collègue
Colomba me permet de revenir un peu en
arrière parce que je voulais intervenir
en fait sur l'article mais vu qu'il
propose de le
supprimer c'est une explication de vote
moi je voudrais à l'inverse de ce qui
vient d'être dit souligner l'importance
de cet article qui une fois enrichi de
de quelques amendements mettra la France
au niveau des meilleurs standards
internationaux en matière de
transparence l'ambition de cet article
est de mettre en pleine lumière des
activités que tout le monde connaît dont
la presse d'ailleurs qui se fait souvent
l'écho plutôt défavorablement de ce qui
se passe et sur lesquels nos concitoyens
souhaitent que l'on lève le voile les
représentants d'intérêt que l'on peut
appeler lobbyiste existe nous les
connaissons nous en avons même ici un
registre et nous savons que tel ou tel
est souvent sollicité sur quelques
projet que ce soit d'abord il faut
Leever
toute ambigué il ne s'agit pas de
stigmatiser leur activité les
représentants d'intérêts sont utile ceci
étant leur activité n'est possible et
comprise que si elle devient
transparente encadré et contrôlé et il
en va de ce point de vue du lien de
confiance indispensable au bon
fonctionnement de démocratie et à la
légitimité de la décision publique moi
je voudrais à cet instant remercier
aussi les associations et les ONG qui
depuis des années plaide pour cette
transparence et puis par la même
féliciter le travail des députés qui
nous présente aujourd'hui un texte très
intéressant cependant il nous faut
encore renforcer et clarifier le cadre
légal des rapports entre ces
représentants d'intérêt et les pouvoirs
publics il nous faut tout d'abord une
définition large des représentants et
supprimer les exclusions du répertoire
en particulier et nous y reviendrons C
des associations à vocation cultuell il
nous faut aussi un dispositif permettant
à l'acteur public d'obtenir toutes les
information nécessaire sur le
représentant d'intérêt et puis ensuite
il nous faut un mécanisme de sanction
efficace d'ailleurs monsieur Nadal le
président de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique dans une
tribune d'un journal du soir nous
inviter l'ensemble des acteurs publics à
prendre en considération ce qui a été
fait dans le casadre de l'article 26 de
la loi sur la santé qui oblige les
industriels du tabac à déclarer leurs
dépenses de lobying en précisant leur
identité la rémunération des personnes
qui les conduisent et si c'est valable
pour le tabac il n'y a pas de raison que
ça puisse être valable pour l'ensemble
des autres activités industrielles et
commerciales merci Monsieur Marie alors
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
des lois sur l'amendement monsieur
Colomba oui alors sur ce premier
amendement je va faire des
développements un peu plus larges ce qui
évitera d'ailleurs de les faire par la
suite il faut cesser d'imaginer que le
lobbyiste est quelqu'un de fourbe de
corrompu ou
d'infréquentable le lobbyist c'est
quelquefois celui qui nous permet de
corriger
l'insuffisance de certaines études
d'impact et il est normal que il est
normal
que chaque parlementaire est la
possibilité d'écouter qui Il
veut aprs en faire ce qu'il
veut donc en l'espèce tout ce qui va
être discuté ce soir c'est uniquement la
transparence que l'on veut améliorer
dans la vision par no cons citoyen de
l'élaboration de la décision publique de
l'élaboration de la loi de l'élaboration
du
règlement le Sénat n'avait pas de leçons
à recevoir pas plus que l'assemblée
puisque depuis très long
nous avons créé notre registre de
lobbyistes de représentants d'intérêts
et que en revanche ça n'existait pas
pour le gouvernement c'est-à-dire qu'on
ne savait pas comment le gouvernement
pouvait êtrefin recevoir des
informations de certains groupes
d'intérêt à juste
titre le
Gouvernement présente son projet de loi
qui est radicalement différent de celui
qui nous arrive de l'Assemblée nationale
parce parce qu'au départ le gouvernement
ne veut absolument pas réglementer notre
manière d'appréhender les lobbyistes au
sein des différentes assemblées c'est
l'Assemblée nationale qui s'imagine de
créer un répertoire
unique qu'est-ce que la commission des
lois a fait premier point elle a vérifié
attention nous sommes en République il y
a des principes il y a des pouvoirs
constitutionnels on respecte leur
indépendance ce qui fait que il n
artient pas à qui que ce soit et en
particulier à l'aut autorité qui ne le
veut pas président Nadal l'a dit de
fixer la liste de ceux qui auront le
droit d'entrer dans la salle des
conférences pour nous contacter ça
restera de la compétence du Sénat
qu'est-ce qu'a fait la commission des
lois elle a étanché ce fait mais elle a
dit vous voulez un répertoire unique
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas nous allons
prendre celui du Sénat nous allons
prendre celui de l'Assemblée nationale
nous allons prendre celui qui va être
créé par la Haute Autorité pour le
gouvernement et puis la Haute Autorité
fera en quelque sorte une liste par
ordre alphabétique que sais-je qu'elle
transmettra à nos concitoyens de toute
façon on peut pas l'empêcher n'importe
quelle association
noosénateur.com nosdputés.com peuvent
parfaitement donner la liste des gens
qui sont inscrits dans les différentes
assemblées nous avons donc veillé à bien
respecter la compétence et surtout
l'indépendance
de de nos assemblées je note d'ailleurs
avec intérêt et je veux le dire que
l'essentiel des des amendements que j'ai
proposé que la commission des lois a
retenu et qui s'inscrit donc dans cette
architecture que le gouvernement de
temps en temps il faut dire les choses
agréables quand elles peuvent être dites
s'est abstenu conformément à une
tradition républicaine respecté et
respectable de déposer des amendements
sur les dispositions intéressant les
assemblées
le donc la commission elle a été guidée
par quelques idées maîtresses je vous ai
donné la première un répertoire commun
et souhaitable je reprends
la la dénomination qu'a employé le
président Nadal président Nadal a dit
surtout on touche pas à l'indépendance
mais nous ferons une plateforme
technique c'est tout c'est une
plateforme technique et de toute façon
le texte que vous propose la Commission
en en aucun cas en aucun cas la Haute
autorité ou qui que ce soit n'influe sur
notre règlement et sur notre gestion car
tout est protégée en revanche la Haute
Autorité la Haute Autorité gérera les
groupes d'intérêts qui
s'intéresseront au gouvernement voilà
donc quel
est
l'ossature de cette de cette de ce texte
tel que sorti de la commission des lois
et je vous indique que d'ailleurs nous
avons distrait les collectivités
territoriales de ce dispositif j'aurai
l'occasion donc de revenir à l'occasion
des examen pour vous donner des
précisions sur ce point en ce qui
concerne celui de Monsieur Colomba ben
il est évident qu'il est contraire à la
position de la Commission car il propose
tout simplement de supprimer l'article
13 dans sa rédaction adoptée en
commission alors l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président euh je
pense que c'est un moment important de
notre débat et je ne vais pas répéter ce
qu'a dit votre rapporteur parce que je
suis je crois d'accord avec 100 % de ces
arguments je vais essayer de les
compléter ou éventuellement de les les
préciser pourquoi j'entends quelqu'un
non c'est pas à propos de ça donc je
suis 100 % d'accord avec les arguments
du
rapporteur j'espère que ça vous
convient est-ce que nous avons inventé
quelque chose de totalement nouveau la
réponse est non d'abord c'est un
dispositif qui existe à l'étranger là
encore je ne suis pas pour qu'on copie
toujours ce qui se passe à l'étranger
mais de temps en temps on fait des
comparaisons il vous arrive messieurs
les sénateurs mesdames les sénatrices de
nous comparer à tel ou tel autre pays et
vous avez raison même si la comparaison
n'est pas raison la comparaison
peut-être utile les institution
européenne par le Parlement européen
peut-être certains d'entre vous ont-ils
été parlementaires européens avec un tel
registre
et argument qui me paraît décisif que le
rapporteur vient de décrire d'elle même
les deux assemblées le Sénat comme
l'Assemblée nationale ont décidé
librement les bureaux ont décidé
librement de mettre en place dans
chacune des assemblées un registre le
dispositif existe déjà il n'est pas
question d'ailleurs le rapporteur vient
très bien le décrire de modifier les
registres qui existent ni à l'Assemblée
nationale ni au Sénat ce qui existe
continuera à fonctionner de la même
manière et seule la volonté libre et
protégée du Sénat pour ce qui concerne
le Sénat ou de l'Assemblée nationale
pour ce qui concerne l'Assemblée
nationale pourra faire évoluer le
dispositif ça existe déjà cela vous
concerne déjà cela concerne déjà un très
grand nombre d'associations ou de
groupes qui n'ont pas peur de dire que
c'est nécessaire de pouvoir prendre
contact avec vous pour éclairer votre
jugement garder votre liberté de
jugement évidemment mais vous pouvez
être éclairé par ce jugement ce que nous
proposons c'est j'allais dire ça n'est
que enfin ça n'est pas rien que le même
dispositif que celui que vous avez
choisi de vous appliquer soit appliqué
aussi au gouvernement voilà la
proposition au
gouvernement le Parlement vous avez
décidé librement au gouvernement je je
veux vraiment que ce soit clair dans la
tête des uns et des autres parce que
j'ai parfois écouté des interventions on
avait le sentiment que ça vous
concernait monsieur Colom non vous avez
déjà décidé c'est déjà comme ça que ça
se passe ici totalement librement déjà
comme ça que ça se passe vous soyez en
désaccord avec le dispositif je veux
bien le croire mais c'est déjà ce que
librement votre bureau a choisi de faire
il y a plusieurs années donc que les
choses soient claires de ce point de
vue-là ensuite mais je ne veux pas aller
plus loin que ce qu'a dit le rapporteur
il faut éviter de considérer queun
représentant d'intérêt serait une forme
de délincant potentiel il fait valoir
des arguments mais même des arguments de
défense d'intérêts je sais pas s'il faut
les dire privés ils peuvent être
collectivement défendus mais concerné
des personnes privées sont des arguments
utiles sont même des arguments
nécessaires
d'ailleurs nous sommes en débat depuis
hier à écouter les uns ou et les autres
parfois à lire les amendements des uns
ou des autres j'ai le sentiment et je ne
le critiquerai pas qu'il y a des
représentants d'intérêt qui vous ont
rencontré et qui vous ont permis
d'éclairer votre jugement et parfois
même d'éclairer votre plume dans
l'écriture d'un certain nombre
d'amendements et c'est donc utile pour
vous ils peuvent être utile pour le
gouvernement est-ce que vous voulez un
gouvernement qui soit fermé aux autres
c'est parfois le reproche que l'on fait
aux uns comme aux autres quel que soit
ses gouvernements non il doit être
ouvert aux autres simplement dans la
transparence comme vous l'avez décidé
pour vous-même donc le gouvernement vous
propose d'appliquer au gouvernement les
mêmes règles que celles que vous avez
décidé de vous appliquer à
vous-même bon monsieur
Colomba moi je ne suis pas contre la
transparence mais je suis contre
l'apparence de la
transparence alors les exemples
étrangers ah les exemples étrangers une
anecdote quand le délire déontologique a
commencé à r à régner sur ce pays la
Commission des lois est allé voir à
l'étranger parce que à l'étranger on
fait des choses absolument
extraordinaires bien avec une mission
donc de la commission des lois il av
mené par le le doyen Géard on est allé à
Washington est allé voir les sénateurs
alors les sénateurs américains il
remplissent des pavés de 1000
pages avant de de prendre leur poste on
est allé voir le président de la
Commission de dirutologie et cetera ils
sont bien bien quand même bon et moi je
lui ai posé la question je lu dit mais
ça fait 20 ans que la Commission est en
fonctionne monsieur le Président est-ce
que vous pouvez me dire combien de
sénateurs ont été
inquiétés oh il m'a dit trois don un
pour harcèlement
sexuel donc bon et quand on sait
excusez-moi mais quand on sait aux
États-Unis que les lobby sont
parfaitement légaux qui a pas de limite
de financement des campagnes électorales
de la vie de la Cour suprême qu'il
existe des fondations financées par les
lobis pour financer le train de vie des
parlementaire excusez-moi si c'est pas
ce moquer du monde c'est pas ce moquer
du monde qu'est-ce que c'est
transparency internationale vous êtes
allé voir un peu qu'est-ce qui le le
le le classement transparencie
intellectuelle international c'est quoi
c'est pas le résultat d'une enquête et
cetera si d'enquête
d'opinion c'est le
ressenti on interroge les gens est-ce
que vous croyez que
le quel est le niveau de la corruption
et cetera et après on fait un classement
et quand vous voyez que dans ce
classement
la France est en 23e position dans le
dernier il y a devant le
Luxembourg le Qatar Hong
Kong on est juste juste devant le les
les Émirats arabes
unis on se dit quand même on pourrait
regarder un peu plus près la qualité
alors mais non mais comme ça tourne en
boucle regardez la France elle est
corrompue enfin et cetera et ben voilà
on va faire comme eux comme ça au moins
les journaux seront contents mais non
moi je ne suis pas pour ce type de de
chose je ne suis pas pour le dé ement de
l' de cette a du faux
semblant monsieur anzi
oui je ne résiste pas au plaisir de
prendre la parole après Pier Colomba
nous étions tous les deux dans le même
voyage B l'évidence nous n'avons pas les
mêmes lunettes il en a et je n'en ai pas
mais je pense avoir une aussi bonne vue
que lui et en réalité en réalité mais
c'était une mission officielle du du du
Sénat et j'ai la même expérience que
Pier Colomba mais je n'ai pas les mêmes
souvenirs je trouve que c'est très
intéressant aux États-Unis le système
est complètement différent c'est qu'aux
États-Unis ce que l'on exige c'est la
transparence il faut dire il faut dire
on est dans cet hémicycle il faut
prendre la parole en disant je ne vais
pas intervenir parce que j'ai tel et tel
intérêt donc je ne participe pas au
débat et je ne participe pas au vote
c'est ça la règle américaine et celui
qui ne respecte pas cette règle
américaine alors une sanction arrive des
publications avec des registres chéif
pierre Coloma justement existe et là
c'est la différence avec notre pays
c'est livré ensuite après à l'opinion
publique c'est vrai qu'il n'y a que
trois condamnations pour ces motifs il
il dit la vérité lorsqu'il dit ça mais
il dit que la moitié de la vérité parce
que en réalité il y a beaucoup plus
ensuite après d'ennui de procès et de
démission et de démission parce que la
presse s'en empare parce que l'opinion
s'en empare et ensuite après il y a des
sanctions qui sont très dures qui sont
appliquées aux différents parlementaires
c'est le cas pour les maires ça peut
même être le cas pour des ministres et
même dans beaucoup de pays en Europe on
a vu des pays en Europe où des ministres
espagnols ont démissionné justement pour
des questions de transparence voilà
simplement je voulais rapporter aussi ce
témoignage pour montrer que la
transparence est vraiment vraiment une
vertu indispensable dans une
démocratie monsieur Vassel a demandé la
parole merci monsieur le président moi
en écoutant les uns et les autres je
n'étais pas présent lorsque vous avez
voté la loi de 2013 pour la lutte contre
la corruption moi je me demande et je
pose la question au gouvernement à quand
la prochaine loi contre la corruption
que ça date pas d'aujourd'hui qu'on
légifère dans ce domaine on a commencé
en 1992 en 1993 lorsque Christian Bonet
a rapporté le premier texte de lutte
contre la corruption pour justement
essayer de faire en sorte que nous
n'aboutissions pas à des situations
telles que celles qui ont été doné
récemment est-ce que s'il n'y avait pas
eu l'affaire Cusac aurions-nous légiféré
dans ce domaine j'en suis pas certain je
n'en suis pas certain donc je trouve
qu'on fait preuve d'un peu d'excè Zè et
nous en rajoutons tout le temps en
permanence et que l'on crée dans
l'opinion en votant des textes de lois
de cette nature on renforce le doute de
nos concitoyens à l'égard de la probité
des parlements
donc bon le texte est là il faut faire
avec je remercie le rapporteur de nous
avoir éclairé sur ce qu'il a animé dans
la rédaction donc de cet article de cet
article 13 ceci
étant la proposition faite par notre
collègue Colomba est sans doute une
solution radicale mais dans l'état
actuel de la législation et contenu des
disposition qui ont été voté
précédemment je ne pense pas que ce soit
la bonne solution il vaut mieux procéder
aux aménagements tels qui sont proposé
par le rapporteur c'est la raison pour
laquelle je ne suivrai pas monsieur
Colomba même si j'apprécie nombre de ses
interventions la décision la conférence
plus personne ne demande la parole mes
chers
collègues alors dans ce cas-là je vais
mettre au voix l'amendement de notre
collègue ah pardon monsieur le Président
décidément je vous avis je vous prie de
m'excuser monsieur le Président et je ne
veux surtout pas prolonger le débat qui
est d'ailleurs très riche et et très
intéressant je crois qu' il faut il faut
le dire euh je voudrais tout de même
souligner que pour nous il y a une
question de de principe c'est que euh le
l'organisation du travail parlementaire
ne peut être régie par la Loi euh ce qui
régit l'organisation du travail
parlementaire c'est d'abord l'ordonnance
de 1958 qui est très particulière cette
ordonnance puisque c'est pas une
ordonnance de l'article 38 de la
Constitution
sur la base d'une loi d'habilitation
c'est une ordonnance prise sur la base
d'une disposition constitutionnelle pour
l'entrée en vigueur de la Constitution
de la 5e République et cette ordonnance
de manière tout à fait dérogatoire et
exceptionnelle intervient dans un
domaine qui relève normalement du
règlement de chacune de nos assemblées
car seul le règlement de nos assemblées
doit normalement pouvoir régir
l'organisation du travail des députés et
des sénateurs par exception nous avons
continué à faire reposer une partie des
règles relatives à notre travail sur
l'ordonnance de 1958 qui a été modifié
plusieurs fois mais ce que nous pouvons
admettre c'est que la loi ordinaire
viennent interférer avec les règles
posées par l'ordonnance de 58 et avec
les règles que le règlement intérieur de
notre assemblée peut poser la deuxième
chose que je parce que c'est la
séparation des pouvoirs le législ Atur
ordinaire ne peut pas régir les
modalités du travail de nos assemblées
la deuxième chose et cela vaut
d'ailleurs pour la présidence de la
République de la même façon que pour
nous et également pour le Conseil
constitutionnel car ce sont des pouvoirs
publics constitutionnels ils sont
institués directement par la
Constitution et sont les rouages du
fonctionnement de notre démocratie la
deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que il ne nous paraît pas possible
même si l'assemblée national l'avait
d'ailleurs prévu d'une manière
extraordinairement timide de prévoir que
la Haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie politique puisse faire la
moindre observation à un membre du
Parlement sur la manière dont il
organise pour son travail les relations
avec les représentants des forces vives
de notre pays et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la Commission a tenu à écarter
toute interférence de la Haute Autorité
avec le travail des parlementaires la
Haute autorité peut naturellement se
prononcer sur le comportement des
représentants des groupements d'intérêt
mais pas sur la manière dont nous
organisons nous parlementaires nos
relations avec les représentants des
forces vives relations nécessaires et
même indispensable pour un travail
législatif de qualité donc pas de Haute
autorité pour donner des avis ou des
conseil aux parlementaires sur ces
relations que nous entretenons
légitimement
enfin le troisème point c'est que le
Sénat n'a pas attendu la loi ou la ou le
projet de loi dont nous discutons pour
se préoccuper de la régulation de nos
relations avec les représentants des
groupes d'intérêt puisque dès 2009 à
l'initiative du président Larcher avec
notre collègue le sénateur
Dupont une instruction générale du
bureau a été émise qui Figur dans les
documents statutaires de notre assemblée
pour régir les modalités de
l'inscription de groupes
d'intérêt sur la liste des groupes
d'intérêt habilité à être présent au
Sénat dans un certain nombre de locaux
et que nous vérifions il y a d'ailleurs
eu des refus d'inscription que ces
groupes d'intérêt sont des groupes
d'intérêts fréquentable
ce qui est tout de même la moindre des
choses et je voudrais donc souligner que
tout le sens du travail de la commission
ça va consister ça a consisté à vous
proposer de rattacher à l'ordonnance de
1958 qui régit le travail parlementaire
au rôle du bureau des assemblées les
relations avec les groupes d'intérêt en
excluant que le législateur ordinaire
puisse intervenir dans ce domaine et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite naturellement que la position
de la Commission soit soit
suivi
alors nous arrivons quand même à
l'amendement de Monsieur Colomba donc
ceux qui sont d'avis de voter
l'amendement de Monsieur Colomba
veuillez bien le manifester en levant la
main avis
contraire allez l'avandem de Monsieur
Colomba n'est pas adopté dans la
discussion des articles du projet de loi
nous sommes parvenus à l'amendement
648 au sein de l'article
13 donc dans cet article 13 nous avons
quatre amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune et le premier
le 648 présenté par le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
c'est un plaisir de parler sous votre
présidence pardon
j'en perd mon petit chapeau
là euh c'est un débat que que que vous
avez eu en commission qui a eu lieu
aussi à l'Assemblée nationale qui a lieu
ici la question étant de savoir si le
président de la République et le Conseil
constitutionnel peuvent être placé sous
le même régime ce qui serait pas du tout
en soit déshonorant loin de là c'est pas
la question du tout posée puisque nous
avons tous dit et redit que être en
contact avec des représentants d'intérêt
était chose tout à fait normale
nécessaire au bon fonctionnement de la
démocratie mais là c'est vraiment pour
des raisons d'ordre constitutionnel il
me semble bien d'ailleurs que le Conseil
d'État avait fait des remarques sur sur
ce point que il me paraît nécessaire de
ne pas mettre le président de la
République et le Conseil constitutionnel
dans le champ du dispositif institué par
l'article 13 voilà vraiment les les
raisons pour lesquelles je le répète
c'est pas du tout pour exclure telle ou
telle institution comme s'il les tit je
répète déshonorant d' être en contact
avec des représentants d'intérêt c'est
le cas pour le président de la
République ce peut être éventuellement
le cas pour le conseil constitunel ou
ses membres mais je pense que nous nous
n'avons pas la possibilité juridique de
les soumettre au même dispositif que
celui qui concerne l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement de même que vous
l'avez dit et répété je l'ai fait avec
vous il n'est pas possible de soumettre
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat au
même dispositif que celui qui concerne
les ministres comme
moi-même merci le 356 tif monsieur
Cabanel le présente oui merci monsieur
madame la Présidente le président amadem
a pour objet de préciser que les règles
applicable au représentant d'intérêt
entrant en communication avec le
président de la République où un de ses
collaborateurs sont rendu public cette
publicité doit renforcer la confiance et
citoyens en leur institution en
améliorant la transparence du processus
d'élaboration de la décision
publique si vous présenter les deux
suivants aussi le 167 rectifié bis et le
357 rectifié le le le 167 167 d'abord
oui l'article 13 s'attache à clarifier
les rapports des représentants d'intérêt
avec les pouvoirs publics il s'attache
tout particulièrement au Parlement les
déontologues de l'Assemblée nationale et
du Sénat contrôlent la détermination des
règles applicables aux relations avec
les représentants d'intérêt au vu de
l'importance du respect de ces règles le
présent amendement prévoit de rendre
systématique l' vie de l'organe chargé
de la déontologie parlementaire celui-ci
n'est pour l'instant que facultatif
lorsque ce dernier constaterait qu'un
parlementaire un collaborateur du
président de l'Assemblée intéressé d'un
parlementaire ou d'un groupe constitué
au sein de cette Assemblée ainsi que des
agents titulaires des services des
assemblées parlementaires a répondu
favorablement à une sollicitation
effectuée par un représentant d'intérêt
à mesconnaissan des règles arrêtées par
le bureau il devra en aviser la personne
concerné tout manquement déontologique
doit être signalé à son
auteur bien le suivant
357 le suivant donc a pour objet de
préciser que les règles applicablesés
résentant d'intérêt entrant en
communication avec les membres du
Conseil constitutionnel ou son
secrétaire général sont rendus
publ alors avis de la commission sur ces
amendements oui madame la Présidente
alors l'amendement du Gouvernement
soulève évidemment un débat intéressant
sur le niveau juridique des règles qui
sont adopté pour encadrer le répertoire
commun l'Assemblée nationale avait a
étendu ce rege au président de la
République à l'Assemblée nationale au
Sénat et au Conseil constitutionnel bon
le gouvernement souhaite retirer le chef
de l'État au motif que ces règles
seraient d'ordre constitutionnel car
éélève de son
statut oui si nous suivons ce
raisonnement la fixation de ces règles
devrait également relever du statut
euh des parlementaires c'est la raison
pour laquelle la timidité rédactionnelle
de votre amendement fait que je n'y
seraai pas euh favorable puisque nous
avons en ce qui concerne la commission
estimer que ces règles ne sont relatives
ni au statut des pouvoirs publics
constitutionnels ni à l'organisation ou
au fonctionnement de ces institutions
mais qu'elles sont relatives aux
relations que ces pouvoirs publics
peuvent nouer avec des tiers ce que là
la Constitution ne réserve pas à la loi
organique en l'état de notre réflexion
en l'état de notre réflexion c'est un
avis défavorable pour les trois autres
de Monsieur Cabanel la commission des
lois Ava sucité suggéré sollicité des
modifications rédactionnelles qui ont
été faites ces trois avis
favorables alors avis du gouvernement
sur les amendements autres que oui
madame la Présidente ça ne vous étonnera
pas je suis pour mon amendement et donc
je ne peux pas être favorable au aux
trois autres amendements qui sont
parfaitement contradictoires avec celui
que je viens de
défendre alors je vais mettre au
voie l'amendement du
Gouvernement qui a donc reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour qui est contre
qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement suivant le 356 rectifié
avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstien il est adopté même
vote je suppose pour le 167 rectifié et
même vote pour le
357 voilà donc sont adopté nous arrivons
au 341 rectifiers co TER et c'est
monsieur longjau qui le
présente merci madame la présidente
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues euh ce projet de loi
ambitionne de renforcer la transparence
de la décision publique notamment par la
création d'un répertoir public des
représentants d'intérêt auprès du
gouvernement des parlementaires des élus
ou encore des hauts- fonctionnaires
toutefois il semble nécessaire d'aller
plus loin c'est pour cela que je
propose que chaque projet de loi chaque
proposition de loi ou encore chaque
amendement indique de façon complète les
références précises sur lesquelles il
s'appuie cela peut-être tout aussi bien
des données issues d'études
scientifiques d'études statistiqu mais
également des auditions des rencontres
parfois avec les 10 représentants
d'intérêt évoqués dans ce répertoire
public en effet pouvoir apporter une
justification ainsi qu'une explication
des références utilisées dans
élaboration des textes législatifs
permet tout aussi bien aux citoyens de
comprendre comment a été élaboré et
c'est important cette loi que de
comprendre quels sont les acteurs
concernés et les processus en œuvre la
Commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme considère par exemple
qu'une telle mesure est pertinente pour
lutter contre la désinformation celle-ci
donnant l'impression que la loi est
prise dans l'oppposité suscitant
réserves et suspicions tout aussi bien à
l'égard des parlementaires que des
représentants d' intérêt alors même que
ces derniers peuvent apporter un apport
bénéfique à la prise de décision je vous
remercie merci avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur oui cet
amendement propose d'obliger à préciser
les références ayant conduit au dépôt
d'une proposition de loi ou d'un
amendement or l'argumentation qui est en
faveur d'une d'une solution législative
nous l'avons déjà dans l'exposé des
motifs des proposition de loi nous
l'avons dans l'objet des amendements et
nous l'avons dans le débat parlementaire
euh lui-même
je passe sur les difficultés matérielles
qu'il y aurait que nous
rencontriion pour mettre en œuvre cet
amendement mais enfin cet amendement
paraît contraire à l'article 39 de la
Constitution qui n'encadre pas
l'initiative parlementaire et surtout
l'article 44 de cette même constitution
qui renvoie s'agissant des amendements à
la loi organique c'est donc un avis
défavorable avis du gouvernement sagesse
sagesse donc je mets au voix cet
amendement avec un avis défavorable de
la commission sagesse du gouvernement
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement suivant
euh il est retiré le suivant
euh monsieur CIN le présente le 56 de
rectifier oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues cet amendement vise à exclure
du répertoire les représentants
d'intérêts n'ayant de relation qu'avec
les membres du gouvernement leur mission
implique justement de rencontrer un
grand nombre d'interlocuteurs afin de
s'assurer de la bonne mise en œuvre des
politiques publiques qu'ils définissent
l'article 13 prévoit la création d'un
répertoire destiné à accroître la
transparence des rapports entre les
représentants d'intérêts et les pouvoirs
publics or Leit fait de publier une
liste interlocuteurs régulier ou
occasionnel des pouvoirs publics ou même
un tableur faisant état des dépenses
engagées par chacun de ces
interlocuteurs ne permettra pas de
refléter la réalité et la qualité de
leur relation avec ses pouvoirs en outre
les règles relatives à l'encadrement du
travail des représentants d'intérêt on
déjà été défini par chaque assemblée
voilà le sens de cet amendement merci
merci avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur oui les deux amendements
d'ailleurs l'amendement 562 mais ça udra
pour le suivant revienne à réduire
totalement néant le dispositif qui est
proposé initialement par le par le
gouvernement puisquil retire les membres
du gouvernement et les membres de leur
cabinet du champ d'application du
répertoire ce quiétait l'objectif
initial de la loi donc à l'évidence
c'est un avis
défavorable même avis alors je
mets je mets au voix le 560 de rectifier
deux avis défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 563
rectifié vous avez
déjà bon voilà alors le 95 rectifié
monsieur
adenud merci madame la Présidente il
s'agit donc d'insérer les mots ou liés
par un contrat de collaboration libérale
avec et cet amendement tend à préciser
l'exclusion des collaborateurs libéraux
très bien de la
commission alors cet amendement exclut
du champ des représentants d'intérêt
comme personne physique les
professionnels qui exercent au sein
d'une structure non sous un régime
salarié mais dans un cadre libéral je
pense que cet ajour rend plus obscure la
lecture et en tout cas la rédaction de
l'article de l'alinéa 26 donc je vous en
demande le retrait c'est un avis
défavorable même avis du gouvernement
vous le maintenz ou vous le retirez il
est
retiré alors six amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 1ier
198 rectifi qu TER monsieur longjau
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monieur le rapporteur donc cet
amendement a pour effet de garantir
l'utilité du dispositif créé et il
propose d'élargir la définition des
représentants d'intérêt au syndicat et
sup l'alinéa 30 merci merci le 254
actifi bis monsieur
Dominati il s'agit de la même intention
madame la Présidente et je voudrais
l'illustrer par un exemple tout
simplement il y a une nouvelle
profession qui notamment en milieu
urbain à Paris s'appelle les VTC
actuellement nous sommes confrontés
régulièrement depuis des mois voire
depuis quelques années à des dialogues
en tant qu'élu d'une part avec les
syndicats de taxis d'autre part avec des
représentants des VTC qui ne sont pas
encore organisés en syndicat qui
viennent par l'intermédiaire de leby ou
de groupement d'intérêts voire même
d'avocats et donc en réalité il y a un
profond déséquilibre si on nintègre pas
les syndicats je dirais dans les
dispositions générales que nous prenons
autrement ça n'a véritablement plus de
sens et il faudrait suivre monsieur
Colomba et supprimer l'article
13 alors le 575 rectifié monsieur
oui cet amendement vise donc à faire
bénéficier les syndicats de
fonctionnaires des mêmes dérogations que
les syndicats de salariés dans le cadre
de le relation avec les pouvoirs
publics
665 monsieur piller au nom de la
commission des lois
oui c'est un amendement qui précise la
rédaction de l'exemption en faveur des
organisations syndicales de salariés et
les organisation professionnelle
d'employeur puisque cette exemption est
évidemment limitée au cas de la
négociation prévu à l'article L1 du Code
du travail si vous avez adopté
d'ailleurs cet amendement il répondra à
un certain nombre d'autres qui ont été
présentés par certains d'entre vous le
83 rectifié bis monsieur Vassel
oui il va pas aller dans le sens de ce
que VI déposer monsieur le rapporteur
l'article 13 du projet de loi relatif à
la transparence à la lutte contre la
corruption et la modernisation de la vie
économique créer un répertoire numérique
des représentants d'intérêt dans ce
dispositif les organisations syndicales
de salariés et les organisations
professionnelles d'employeurs qui
doivent s'inscrire au répertoire
numérique des représentants d'intérêts
sont toutefois exempés de reporting sur
les activités liées au dialogue social
mais l'article L1 du Code de travail
cité dispositif renvoie aux
organisations nationales et
interprofessionnelles ce qui est en
incohérence avec la première partie de
la phrase qui fait référence aux
organisations professionnelles
d'employeurs au sens large il il
semblerait logique pour permettre une
équité de traitement sur ce volet de
dialogue social entre organisation
professionnell d'employur et
organisation
interprofessionnelle de supprimer la
référence à l'article 1 donc c'est une
question de nuance entre les
organisations professionnelles et les
interprofessionnelles sauf à ce que
monsieur le rapporteur me précise
qu'avec l'article 1 cela intègre l'un et
l'autre ou l'une et
l'autre très bien et le 564 rectifié
monsieur
Collin alors cet
amendement vise et propose de faire
bénéficier les organisations étudiantes
et les organisations de chômeurs de la
même dérogation que les organisations
syndicales de salariés et les
organisations professionnelles
d'employeurs c'est le sens de cet
amendement merci alors avis de la
commission sur cette série d'amendements
alors je vais me prononcer d'abord sur
les amendements 198
575 83 et 564 puisqu'il étonnera
personne que sur les 665 dont je suis
l'auteur j'en suis particulièrement
partisan euh en ce qui concerne donc ces
amendements il modifie parfois dans des
sens d'ailleurs opposés l'exemption dont
bénéficient les organisations syndicales
de salariés et les organisations
professionnelles d'employeurs qui sont
appelés à participer à la négociation
prévu à l'article L1 du Code du travail
j'insiste sur cette dernière précision
car ces organisations représentatives ou
au niveau national ou interprofessionnel
sont exempé dans la mesure où elles
entre en relation avec les pouvoirs
publics en raison d'une obligation
découlant de la loi elle-même c'est le
sens de l'amendement que j'ai déposé
donc dans ces conditions il serait
évidemment contre-productif de supprimer
cet alinéa car il est logique avec la
concertation qui est imposé au
gouvernement par l'article L1 du code du
travail et contreproductif d'élargir la
définition prévue à cette aniléa ce qui
serait un peu l'effet de votre
amendement car dans ce cas la
justification à l'origine de cette
exemption
euh n'existe
euh pas concrètement ces organisations
qui sont traitées de la même manière si
c'est ça un peu la question entre
l'organisation les organisations
syndicales et les organisations
patronnales euh seront dispensé de
transmettre des informations à la Haute
Autorité lorsque leur participation à
cette concer
lorsquil participeront à cette
concertation mais resteront soumis à
cette obligation lorsqu'elles
chercheront à influencer l'élaboration
de la loi des règlements en dehors du
cadre dans les mêmes conditions et dans
les mêmes dans la même portée pour les
organisations
interprofessionnelles national global
soit salari soit des salariés
soit des
employeurs
donc c'est un avis défavorable pour
l'ensemble de ces amendements y compris
celui qui voudrait faire entrer les
associations de chômeurs et d'étudiants
dans ces
exemptions alors avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
oui madame la Présidente nous sommes
donc dans la
partie des dispositions de cet article
qui exemple entre guillemets est-ce que
le terme est exact bon il fallait bien
en prendre un un certain nombre
d'organisations ou exement un
d'organisation dans un certain nombre de
leurs activités des obligations qui
s'imposent au représentants d'intérêt le
choix qui a été fait qui a d'ailleurs
été fait par la Commission elle-même il
y a une petite modification introduite
par le rapporteur mais au départ il y a
vraiment un accord absolu entre le
Gouvernement l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat le choix qui a été fait c'est dès
lors qu'une disposition législative
explicite donne un rôle à tel ou tel or
organisation alors dans le cadre de ce
rôle et de cette disposition législative
le représentant d'intérêt n'est pas
représentant d'intérêt et donc n'a pas
d'obligation à être déclaré avec tout ce
qui accompagnent cette obligation de
déclaration là le débat porte
principalement sur la question des
syndicats donc monsieur lorsque vous
disiez telle ou telle
organisation dans le domaine du
transport
urbain doit être déclarée elle a déclaré
car elle n'a pas de rôle aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de l'article L1 du Code du
travail qui est un article qui donne je
connais bien pour avoir été ministre du
Travail mais cette assemblée connaît
encore mieux ce L1 car c'est l'œuvre la
création du président Larcher dans un
texte qu'il avait lui-même défendu et
donc l'article L1 donne une
obligation au gouvernement de saisir les
organisations syndicale ou patronnale
représentative cinq d'un côté trois de
l'autre pour négocier sur un se nombre
de dispositions qui concerne le code du
travail cet aspect là des choses est
évidemment sorti du champ de la loi mais
toute organisation syndicale qu'il
s'agisse des représentants de taxis ou
qu'il s'agisse de CGT CFDT Medef ou
autres dans le cadre qui ne rentre pas
dans le enfin pardon dans les activités
qui ne rentrent pas dans le cadre du L1
doivent être déclaré donc en fait vous
avez satisfaction dans votre
préoccupation et je crois que c'est
ainsi qu'il faut bien préciser les
choses alors ça me ça me m'amène
monsieur madame la Présidente à donné un
avis défavorable sur tous les
amendements je voudrais juste dire un
mot sur celui du du rapporteur qui est
parfaitement dans la pardon de prendre
le terme de la ligne en tous les cas
dans le même logique que celle que je
viens deécrire avec une précision qui me
semble-t-il restrain un tout petit peu
trop les dispositions de la loi c'est
pour la raison pour laquelle j'ai la
faiblesse de préférer le texte initial
de la Commission à celui de votre
amendement mais enfin si votre
amendement devait être adopté il n'y a
pas de modification profonde du
raisonnement que je viens de faire donc
à ce stade s'agissant de l'amendement de
Monsieur P le 665 c'est un avis
défavorable et surtout les autres
amendements défavorables défavorbl bien
alors je vais mettre au voix donc le 198
rectifié qui terre deux avis
défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le même vote pour le 575
rectifié n'est pas adopté alors
l'amendement 665 présenté par Monsieur
piller qui lui bien sûr un avis
favorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abs tien il est
adopté les
autres le 83 rectifié bis et 564 Tom
monsieur Vassel
oui il tombe c'est ce que je viens de
dire s'il tombe c'est parfait mais si
vous permettez madame la Présidente de
dire un mot à l'intention du rapporteur
et de Monsieur le Ministre l'objectif de
cet amendement c'était de s'assurer qu'à
la fois les organisations
professionnelles et
interprofessionnelles sont à travers
donc cet article de la loi donc c'est
pas une remise en cause de la référence
à l'article L1 donc ça c'est sans doute
une erreur de la part de de ma part à
travers cet amendement mais l'objectif
deamendement c'était ça à partir
momentement où monsieur le rapporteur
dans son explication a confirmé que l'un
et l'autre sont concernés cet amendement
n'a plus d'objet très bien alors nous
poursuivons deux amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune le
prier le 88 rectifié monsieur Cabanel
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre les associations cultuelles
sont actuellement exclus du champ des
représentants d'intérêts lobby nous nous
étonons d'une telle exclusion comme l'a
montré la loi sur le mariage pour tous
les associations culturel cultuel pardon
ex exerc une influence certaine sur les
pouvoirs publics au même titre que les
associations laïques les associations
cultuelles sont capables d'exprimer des
points de vue et d'actionner leur réseau
au même titre que les autres notamment
dans le champ social sociétal cultel
culturel religieux le présent amendement
vise donc à supprimer cette exclusion
qui ne traite pas les relations de ces
associations comme les autres avec les
pouvoirs publics sur un plein
égalitaire merci le 565 rectifié
monsieur Colin oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues cet amendement vise également
comme le précédent
à vise à restreindre le bénéfice du
régime dérogatoire à la transparence
imposé aux représentants d'intérêt
concernant les associations à objet
cultuels en effet la formule je cite
dans le respect des principes fixés à
l'article 1er de la Constitution nous
paraît trop vague d'une part le respect
de principes constitutionnels s'impose à
toutes les dispositions
infraconstitutionnelles et n'a donc pas
besoin d'être à nouveau ici précisé
d'autre part il serait très ambitieux de
déduire les principes des principes de
laïcité et de respect des croyances que
ces associations cultuelles doivent
bénéficier d'un accès privilégié au
pouvoir public en de du ministre et des
services ministériels chargés des cultes
enfin certains cultes n'adoptent pas le
statut d'association cultuelle une
inégalité de traitement entre les cultes
pourra ainsi découler de cette
disposition c'est le sens de cet
amendement et bien à leur avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur les
amendements ces deux amendements 88 565
sont contraires à la position de la
Commission or la Commission n'a fait que
reprendre une exemption qui figurait
dans le projet de loi initial en
l'adossant sur le modèle des partis des
groupes politique à l'article 1er de la
Constitution
avis sagesse du gouvernement très bien
donc je vais mettre au voit ces
amendements le 88
rectifié sagesse du gouvernement
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
n'est pas
adopté oui oui oui oui oui ah non
mais rassurez-vous on on vous
voit même quand on vous entend pas alors
le 565 rectifié euh même avis sagesse du
gouvernement défavorable de la
commission qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient n'est
pas adopté qure amendements qui font
l'objet de la discussion commune le 566
rectifié monsieur
Collin présidente monsieur le ministre
chers collègues les associations d'élus
concours utilement à la défense du
principe de libre administration des
collectivités territoriales à ce titre
défend de l'intérêt général et non des
intérêts privés cet amendement le
rappelle
remerci bien le 3 rectifié TER monsieur
Vassel
merci madame la Présidente il convient
d'exclure au même titre que les partis
politiques les organisations syndical et
professionnels ou encore les
associations objet cultuells les
associations représentatives d'élus qui
participent au débat public au titre de
leur responsabilité d'intérêt général et
qui ne peuvent être considérés comm des
représentants d'intérêt privé mais Bien
d'Intérêt Public c'est un véritable
problème de principe que d'ignorer la
vocation première des associations
d'élus qui est bien de auprès des
pouvoirs publics les préoccupations des
exécutifs locaux des collectivités
locales leurs actions ne sont guidées
que par la recherche de l'intérêt
général et leurs membres sont tous élus
au suffrage universel dois-je le
rappeler ce qui constitue une différence
de nature évidente avec d'autres lobby
c'est d'ailleurs à ce titre que les
associations d'élus sont présentes dans
nombre d'instances consultatives de
l'État que ce soit le cnen le CSFP ou le
CFL et plusieurs centaines d'autres et
qu'ell répondent quotidiennement aux
sollicitations des représentants de
l'État central ou déconcentré pour
contribuer à la réflexion partagée qui
doit présider à l'élaboration de textes
législatifs ou réglementaires et au
partenariat nécessaires entre l'État et
les collectivités pour la mise en œuvre
des politiques publiques loin de
s'opposer au besoins de transparence les
associations d'élu demande à ce que la
défense de l'intérêt général ne soit pas
assimilée à celle d'intérêt purement
privé mais j'ai cru comprendre de la
bouche de monsieur le ministre qu'il
partageait l'objectif qui était le N
donc je doute pas un seul instant qu'
puisse donner un avis favorable à notre
amendement alors le 10rectifié madame
Gattel
non non tu sais pas quelqu'un d'autre le
présente monsieur
ljou il est défendu parfait monsieur
Vassel pour le 187 rectifi
bis monsieur
Vassel ah c'est un amendement de repli
euh que je propose je ne sais pas ce
qu'en pensera le rapporteur et le
gouvernement simplement nous précisons
euh par parallélisme des formes le
dispositif qui a été adopté pour les
organisations syndicales les
associations représentatives des élus en
tant qu'instance consultative de l'état
du Parlement ainsi que des collectivités
territoriales et leurs groupements donc
il s'agit donc de bien euh circonscrire
ou de définir le périmètre dans lequel
les associations d'élus entrent cont
avec l'État ou le
Parlement alors av de la commission
alors madame la Présidente nous avons
donc trois oui trois amendements de
suppression et un
amendement de repli je vous indique tout
de suite afin de pacifier un éventuel
débat qui pourrait s'irriter que nous
allons pouvoir trouver certainement un
accord sur l'amendement de repli alors
pourquoi pas sur les amendements de
suppression bon alors première il faut
rappeler tout de même et ça c'est
important que un un groupement
d'érêt c'est pas séditieux c'est ce
n'est pas infamant c'est au contraire
parfaitement utile à la vie démocratique
et quelquefois nous en avons la preuve
même quotidiennement pour autant pour
autant les associations
d'élus ont effectivement la possibilité
de temps en de vouloir influer sur la
loi à juste titre mais dans l'obtique de
transparence vis-à-vis des de
concitoyens il est uniquement sollicité
le fait que il s'inscrivent il soit
inscrit pour participer à cette
opération transparent et puis un point
qui est tout de même important qui me
paraît très important c'est que les
associations d'élus bien avant la
réunion de ce soir ont fait la
déclaration qu'ils étaient des groupes
d'intérêt puisqu'ils se sont inscrits
sur les groupes d'intérêt du Sénat et
inscrit sur les groupes de d'intérêt de
l'Assemblée nationale ainsi la MF s
inscrit l'Association des départements
de France s'est inscrit l'association
des élus du littoral s'est inscrit ville
de France s inscrit manifestant en cela
qu'ils avaient parfaitement conscience
de pouvoir être assimilé comme un groupe
d'intérêt ce qui fait que on peut
concevoir que pour une partie de leur
activité ils puissent effectivement en
participant à l'élaboration de la loi en
influant sur le débat
sur l'élaboration de la loi et du
Règlement être considéré comme des
associations des associations des
groupements qui participent donc et qui
font valoir leurs intérêts ou l'intérêt
de leurs membres l'avantage du
dernier amendement qui me paraît
d'ailleurs pouvoir réunir un consensus
c'est que
monsieur Vassel a fort justement comme
ça l' été fait pour les syndicats
distinguer entre certaines formes
d'intervention des associations d'élut
ce qui fait que l'esprit de son
amendement est tout à fait satisfaisant
sans pour autant contredire la position
qu'pris les associations sans qu'on leur
demande l'association des m ça fait la
3è année consécutive qu'elle s'inscrit
sur le groupe sur le le le le registre
des groupes d'intérêt du Sénat la
dernière fois en décembre 2015 alors ce
que je propose donc c'est effectivement
de refuser d' mettre un avis défavorable
sur les amendements de pure suppression
et par comparaison avec ce qui était
fait pour les syndicats sur l'excellente
suggestion de notre collègue Vassel de
prendre son amendement sauf avec une
petite
modification rédactionnelle puisque de
toute façon
le Parlement n'est pas concerné les
collectivités territoriales et leurs
groupements ne sont pas concernés et
d'indiquer que votre amendement serait
le
suivant les associations représentatives
des élus dans le cadre du dialogue avec
le gouvernement là elles sont
exclu bien alors avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre sur cette série
d'amendements alors madame la Présidente
le gouvernement ENF tout les cas
moi-même plutôt envie d'aider à ce que
on puisse trouver une solution à la
question qui est posée d'abord comme l'a
très bien dit comme l'a très bien dit le
rapporteur monsieur le êtes-vous encore
président de l'Association des communes
de montagne je ne me souviens plus
mais comme l'a très bien dit le
rapporteur les associations d'élus sont
déjà aujourd'hui volontairement
d'ell-même inscrite sur des registres de
représentants d'intérêt il y a donc pas
pour elle une n été découvertees comme
ça soudainement elles le sont au titre
des registres de l'Assemblée nationale
et comme du Sénat je pourrais vous en
donner la liste j'ai ici mais elle est
accessible directement sur Internet même
au sein de l'hémicycle vous aurez cette
liste elle comprend tout le monde le
littoral la montagne l'ensemble des
types de collectivités territorial donc
tout le monde est déjà se considère déjà
comme représentant d'intérêt donc je ne
veux pas quitter le raisonnement qui
était le mien au départ il y a des
associations des syndicats organisations
patronales qui ont de par la loi un rôle
qui leur est reconnu de par la loi dans
leexercice de ces fonction reconnu par
la loi évidemment il ne s'agit pas de
représentant d'intérêt au sens où nous
l'entendons ici et donc je vais donner
un avis défavorable comme le rapporteur
aux amendements qui excluent totalement
les associations de d'élus de du
registre de l'obligation d'être sur
inscrit au registre des représentants
d'intérêt mais comme le rapporteur je
pense qu'à partir de l'amendement de
Monsieur Vassel nous pourrions trouver
un accord alors j'ai compris qu'il y
avait une correction ou un
sous-amendement du rapporteur les
associations représentatives
d'élus dans le cadre du dialogue avec le
gouvernement et si on rajoutait c'est ma
proposition et dans les conditions
fixées par la loi et ce et ca et cetera
c'est
lorsque et ça c'est pas une condition
fixée par la loi c'est une condition
fixée par la Constitution monsieur le
sénateur ça ne vous a pas échappé même
si ici par définition vous n'en
connaissez pas l'application puisqueelle
est utilisable que à l'Assemblée
nationale donc donc je je je je je me
tourne vers vous pour voir si vous
seriez d'accord pour qu'on fixe bien
cette cette ce principe même dans les
conditions fixées par la loi on me dit
j'ai dans le en souvenir j'étais
président de région et participé en tant
que vice-président de la RF au côté de
fortes autorités qui siègent ici j'ai
été interlocuteur du gouvernement et
dans le code des comm dans le Code des
Collectivités territorial il est prévu
que pour telle ou telle activité sur tel
ou tel point les associations doivent
être consulté donc c'est pour ça que je
voudrais qu'on fasse bien référence à ce
à ce à ce sujet-là qui est je crois la
préoccupation de beaucoup d'entre vous
donc si vous étiez d'accord sur ce cette
précision je pense qu' enfin je suis sûr
que le gouvernement donnerait un avis
favorable à cet amendement monsur
rapporteur bien dans
l'écriture dans les conditions fixées
par la loi il est rare que le
législateur s'exclut du champ de la loi
donc on pourrait on pourrait éviter de
le mettre mais encore une fois je sens
que ça si ça peut entre le
gouvernement la majorité du Sénat je
pense que là sera unanime conserver
cette rédaction j'en suis d'accord j'ai
sans doute notre confrère notre confrère
pardon notre collègue excusez-moi notre
collègue admettra cette petite
correction supplémentaire alors on va
demander à Monsieur Vassel un avis sur
cette double
modification de son
amendement j'ai compris madame la
Présidente le souci du rapporteur et du
gouvernement d'éviter un débat polémique
entre nous de T manière à ce que nous
puissions trouver une solution de
consensus donc j'y adhère ce d'autant
plus que le texte ne concerne que le
gouvernement puisque le rapporteur a
très bien expliqué que pour ce qui
concerne le Parlement Assemblée
nationale et Sénat ont leur propre
registre en ce qui concerne les
représentants d'intérêt je fais
remarquer quand même à notre rapporteur
qui fait
référence à la présence de des
associations d'élus sur le du Sénat
depuis 2008 s'il l'a été c'est parce que
à l'époque la seule possibilité d'accès
à la MF auprès du Parlement c'était de
figurer sur le registre c'était pour
cette raison et ce que nous ce que nous
dénonçons dans le cadre du dispositif
c'est de confondre le à la fois les
associations représenta Ty d'élus qui
défendent un intérêt général et celles
qui défendre des intérêts privés on ne
peut pas classer dans la même catégorie
les associations de maires qui qui
défendent un intérêt général et les
autres qui défendent un intérêt privé
donc je pense qu'on a trouvé une
rédaction de compromis qui devrait nous
satisfaire j adhère et j'accepte le
sous-amendement proposé par monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur Bouvard a souhaité
prendre la
parole merci madame la
Présidente je vais pas dire des choses
très différentes de de ce qu'a dit notre
collègue Vassel tout d'abord pour faire
une première observation parce que le le
ministre mal usement fait observer
évidemment que nous sommes inscrits sur
les registres au niveau des des
associations d'élu pour en avoir présidé
plusieurs je simplement rappeler que
c'était une quasi condition d'accès d'un
certain nombre de nos collaborateurs
dans les enceintes parlementaires c'est
pas un acte volontaire par laquelle nous
aurions considéré à un moment ou un
autre que nous aurions le même statut
que l'association des Amis du cochon ou
que les
producteurs de de moisson batteuse qui
aurait à venir expliquer en quoi leur
activité professionnelle est importante
et obtenir quelques modifications
législatives ou réglementair dans ce
sens ça c'est le premier point le
deuxème point moi je me rallie
volontiers à une rédaction qui puisse
être
satisfaisante sous réserve qu'il soit
bien
explicité au sein de cette inte afin que
les débats puissent
ultérieurement servir dans les
conditions qui pourraient être
nécessaire
que ce statut spécifique qui est reconnu
aux associations d'élus qui sont bien
représentantes d'un intérêt général et
d'élu du suffrage universel que des
contributions de collectivité au
fonctionnement de ces associations que
des déplacements effectués par les élus
dans le cadre de ces associations ne
relève pas d'activité privée et pourrait
un jour être mis en cause par tel ou tel
euh contestataire qui considérerait
qu'il s'agit là d'un détournement de
moyens public au bénéfice d'intérêt
privé il faut que cette chose-là soit
explicitée soit dite soit enregistrée de
manière à ce qu'on a'ille pas nourrir
des contentieux futurs dans le pour
celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui exercent
des responsabilités dans le cadre de ces
associations ou serait à même à être
consulté ou à faire des déplacements
pour ces
associations merci Monsieur RPP
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur que c'est beau le dialogue
finalement parce que d'une situation qui
nous apparissait fermée on voit une
certaine
évolution dans le texte et le
sous-amendement de d'Alain Vassel semble
amendé par le rapport semble
satisfaisant au demeurant il me reste et
ça va
directement en même ligne que le
discours de notre collègue à
l'instant la
problématique de la relation entre
l'association et le Parlement imaginez
un président d'association
parlementaire le problème c'est celui du
reporting doit-on faire un reporting à
la minute toutes les 10 minutes toutes
les 15 minutes toutes les heures les
jours tous les mois on a un vrai
problème sur cette question et de la
même façon je n'aimerais pas qu'on nous
oppose parce que la loi n'aurait pas été
assez claire que dans quelques mois on
déclare une incompatibilité entre une
présidence d'association d'élus et le
fait d'être
parlementaire merci alors donc nous
allons mettre au
voix ah pardon monsieur
desess
personnellement je ne n'approuve pas le
ce que vous appelez votre amendement de
compromis monsieur le rapporteur
d'ailleurs je n'était pas pour
l'amendement que vous aviez déposé pour
les syndicats dans quel avec des
conditions précises déjà on catégorise
ça va pas être facile mais il faut bien
faire des choix donc on dit les
syndicats ils ont ils sont exemptés
parce qu'ils jouent un rôle social
important ils sont dans beaucoup de
commissions paritaires vous mettez des
restrictions donc on va être obligé de
réfléchir pour les
à quel moment ils sont exempés et à quel
moment ils sont pas et là vous faites la
même chose pour les associations d'élus
alors peut-être que c'est un compromis
pour les 100 personnes qui sont là les
100 parlementaires qui sont là mais ça
va être ingérable on n'est pas on fait
pas la loi et des amendements pour se
faire plaisir entre nous ici on fait
pour que ça soit appliqué et efficace
ensuite alors là on va dire les
associations d'élus lorsqu'elles sont en
négociation avec le gouvernement là
effectivement ils sont zantés mais
autrement non mais que ça va être
épouvantable comment va pouvoir
classifier cela donc pour faire plaisir
et pour pas dire non comme vous l'avez
dit aux associations d'élus on complique
la loi et on la rend difficilement
applicable donc personnellement je ne
voterai pas cela je serai minoritaire
mais au moins j'aurai la conscience pour
moi très bien alors nous allons mettre
au voix le 566
rectifié le 5 ah monsieur le
rapporteur une réponse il peut pas y
avoir de confusion ni maintenant ni à
terme
entre les représentants d'intérêts
privés dont on croit à tort qu'il
seraient les seuls concernés par ces
registre et les organismes publics la
preuve la preuve je vous dire déjà sur
le registre du Sénat vous avez la SNCF
vous avez le Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique vous avez l'ONF vous avez
laacnil et vous avez la Haute
Autorité donc il y aura pas de il y a il
y a comment dirais-je parosmos par effet
buvard euh les euh représentants
d'intérêts privés
ne comment dirais-je n'atterriront pas
sur euh la sphère de compétenence des
associations que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure je vous rassure totalement trs
bien pas d'autres remarques alors le je
mets au voix le
566 rectifié deux avis défavorables qui
est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est pas adopté
même vote
pour le Tro rectifié TER et le 10
rectifié et nous a ah madame
Gatel la Présidente je ne sais pas si
vous avez mis le 10 au vote j'aurais
voulu intervenir avant euh pour dire que
euh le Sénat confirme encore qu'il est
le lieu de la sagesse je pense qu'on
avait sur le texte une vraie difficulté
au regard de la position et de la valeur
ajoutée des associations d'l je remercie
l'excellence du rapporteur et
l'excellence de la proposition de mon
collègue faasel donc je retire cet
amendement bon il est retiré et donc
nous arrivons au 187 rectifié TER qui
qui don a été monsieur
Vassel après l'intervention de notre
collègue le sénateur de cessar il y a
aucune complication chers collègues de
l'application du dispositif alors je
peux comprendre que vous soyez vous ayez
une position radicale qui voudrait qu'on
fasse disparaître la totalité de la
liste qui apparaît dans cet article mais
vouloir maintenant maintenir par exemple
les syndicats et ne pas mettre les
associations élu ça nous mettrait en
complète contradiction avec parce que
monsieur le rapporteur a fait remarquer
que apparaissait dans la liste des
représentants d'intérêt du Parlement et
du S en particulier la C et d'autres
organis et je fais remarquer que la CFDT
y paraît également et le MF et le medf
donc il y aurait une véritable
incompréhension à ce que les
associations représentatives d'élus qui
défendent un intérêt général
lorsqu'elles sont en dialogue avec le
gouvernement n'apparaissent pas dans le
listing point c'est pas plus compliqué
que
çaci merci madame la Présidente
Gouro je voudrais juste remercier aussi
le ministre puisque ça n'a pas été
fait pour avoir soutenu bien sûr la
position du rapporteur et le remercier
aussi de respecter au fond la séparation
des pouvoirs c'est quelque chose de très
important entre l'exécutif et le
législatif merci et bien alors je vais
le à Monsieur
madame la Présidente je me sens obligé
également d' d'intervenir tout
simplement pour moi aussi me féliciter
de l'accord qui vient d'être trouvé ce
n'était pas simple chacun l'a dit tout à
l'heure je comprends certaines
observations de de gens Desessard mais
je les partage pas parce qu'
effectivement je crois que c'est un
équilibre qui vient d'être trouvé qui
devrait fonctionner puisque là on
précise que c'est les association de
représentants des élus mais pas dans
toutes leur fonction dans une dimension
précise qui est le dialogue avec l'État
pour le reste elles resteront soumises
aux différentes obligations qu'on trouve
page 26 de ce petit livre et donc aussi
soumise au contrôle de la Haute Autorité
donc je trouve que c'est un équilibre
tout à fait
intéressant merci Monsieur Anziani alors
je vais mettre au voix cet amendement
187 rectifié terre tel qu'il a été euh
modifié et donc avec deux avis
favorables qui est
pour
qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
l'amendement
suivant madame canailler pour le 137
rectifié terire merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre donc cet
amendement va dans le même sens que le
précédent mais concerne cette fois-ci
les organismes à but lucratif qui procèd
à la fourniture gratuite de repas et euh
à des personnes en difficulté ou qui
contribuent à favoriser leur logement ou
encore qui procèd à titre principal à la
fourniture gratuite de soins mentionné
euh au au premièement du 4e alinéa de
l'article 261 du Code Général des Impôts
tout cela pour des personnes en
difficulté nombre de ces organismes
travaillent avec des bénévoles faisant
preuve de générosité et de solidarité
avec les exclus et personnes en
difficulté il est donc normal qu'il ne
soit pas assez assimilé à des lobbyistes
cette définition est celle qui figure à
l'article 1er de enfin paragraphe 1er
pardon de l'article 200 du code général
des impôts et serait notamment concerné
les restos du cœur la Croix Rouge
Maus la Banque Alimentaire la Fondation
d'uteuil Habitat et Humanisme la
fondation abépierre et le petit frère
des pauvres merci si avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur oui
évidemment le but de la liste n'est pas
de d'en faire une totalement exhaustive
et cet amendement propose de créer une
exemption pour certaines associations
caritatives VO le le le travail de ces
associations ét est évidemment
parfaitement respectable mais dans
l'esprit il est parfaitement normal pour
le citoyen de savoir lorsqu'elle
souhaite
influencer toujours pour des raisons
honorables mais lorsqu'ell souhait
influencer l'élaboration de la loi et du
Règlement c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous nous arrêtons à la liste qui a été
faite sans aller après à décliner euh
toutes les associations euh GIE que
sais-je qui certes ont de très très
bonnes raisons et les vôtres sont les
sorteurs non les meilleurs
euh de euh solliciter cette exenction
mais enfin dans l'esprit pourquoi ces
excellentes raisons de faire modifier la
loi ne serait-elle pas connue du
citoyens donc je demande un retrait
alors même avis même avis du
gouvernement vous le maintenez ou vous
le retirez vous le retirez très bien
alors maintenant nous arrivons à 17
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune et nous commençons
par le
321 monsieur
Marie vous avez la parole merci madame
la Présidente cet amendement vise à
établir dans la loi les modalité et le
rythme de transmission des informations
communiquées à la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique
la commission des lois a supprimé cette
précision pour la renvoyer à la
délibération de la Haute Autorité or si
celle-ci est légitime à déterminer les
modalités pratiques de présentation des
activités du représentant d'intérêt
c'est à la loi de fixer la périodicité
avec laquelle ce représentant d'intérêt
doit satisfaire à ses obligations de
transmission nous proposons en
conséquence d'inscrire à l'article 13
que tout représentant d'intérêt
communique à la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique les
informations exigé par la loi dans un
délai d'un mois à compter du début de
son activité puis à un rythme anuel
merci le suivant 576 rectifié monsieur
Collin merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues cet amendement propose la de
supprimer un certain nombre d'alinéat
l'alinéa 35 à 41 et 50 à 62 ces alinéas
prévoi que la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique est pour
mission de collecter et vérifier de
nombreuses données détaillant l'activité
de chaque représentant d'intérêt et de
contrôler que ces règles soient
respectées selon des modalités
d'application fixées par un décret en
Conseil d'État il ressort de ces
dispositions qu'un pouvoir
d'appréciation considérable sera accordé
à la Haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique alors que la mise en
œuvre de tel règles aurait justement
mérité un débat parlementaire et c'est
pourquoi il est proposé de supprimer ces
alinéas voilà le sens de cet amendement
je vous remercie merci le 322 et
peut-être le 323 monsieur
Marie merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement vise à compléter la liste des
information qui doivent être communiqué
par le représentant d'intérêt à la Haute
Autorité de la transparence de la vie
publique il nous semble en effet
nécessaire que ces représentants
signalent l'origine des fonds qui
soutiennent leur activité ou la
structure pour laquelle ils œuvrent
préciser ces informations financières
aide entre autres à distinguer les
personnes morales ou physiques qui
œuvrent pour l'intérêt général de celle
qui représent un intérêt particulier
cela devrait permettre de s'assurer par
recoupement de la véracité des autres
informations fourni et notamment de
s'assurer que la personne morale
déclarée comme représentant d'intérêt
n'est pas le paravant d'une autre
personne morale le présent amendement
ainsi pour objet de lutter contre
l'ingérence des représentants d'intérêt
dans les politiques publiques et ainsi
de prévenir les conflits d'intérêts 323
monsieur
Marie alors cet amendement a une même
inspiration que le précédent et vise à
compléter lui aussi les informations qui
sont communiquées à la Haute autorité
dans son esprit il reprend le de bis de
l'article 13 voter à l'Assemblée
nationale mais sous une forme différente
simplifiée et nous semble-t-il mieux
intégré dans le schéma global de
l'article 13 l'amendement prévoit qu'à
comptter de sa première année d'exercice
le représentant d'intérêt communique le
bilan de ses activités en précisant le
montant des dépenses et du chiffre
d'affaires associés à ses activités
ainsi que ses sources de financement la
Haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique rend ce bilan public par
l'intermédiaèire d'un Service de
communication en ligne ce bilan annuel
d'activité devra permettre à la Haute
Autorité de mettre en perspective les
autres déclarations fournies et d'en
évaluer la sincérité et la cohérence
sans cet élément de nature qualitatif
nous craignons que les informations
recueilles soit d'une portée assez
limitée et ne permettent pas
d'appréhender dans leur globalité et sur
la durée les activités des représentants
d'intérêt et leur éventuelle influence
sur la vie publique merci le
670 monsieur per au nom de la
correctiontion d'une erreur de référence
d'accord 87 rectifié monsieur Cabanel
oui madame la Présidente le président
amendement précise que l'ensemble des
lobbyistes sont obligés d'établir un
rapport détaillé des dépenses engagées
dans leur travail d'influence le présent
amendement a ainsi pour objet de lutter
contre l'ingérence des représentants
d'intérêts dans dans les politiques
publiques et de prévenir les conflits
d'intérêts merci le 401 rectifié qu TER
monsieur
longjau monsieur
longjau monsieur longjau il est
peut-être
défendu oui il est il est défendu voilà
Monsieur Cabanel pour le 89
rectifié et oui comment vous
faites-vous
dans ce rapport est intitulé renouer la
confiance publique le président de la
Haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique Jean-Louis Nadal
souligne avec pertinence que dans une
démocratie moderne la frontière entre
entre sphère publique et société civile
ne doit en effet pas être étanche si les
élus demeurent les décideurs ultimes
l'intérêt général se conçoit de moins en
moins de manière autoritaire verticale
unilatérale et transcendale la vie des
représentants d'intérêt quel qu'il soit
apporte à l'état une expertise tout au
long du processus de décision qui face à
la complexité à la technicité croissante
des politiques publiques ne peut pas
être négligée cette technicité
croissante les parlementaires que nous
sommes y faisons face tous les jours
nous passons ainsi du dialogue social la
transparence financière de la politique
agricole commune au conséquences du
brexit bref les sujets sur lesquels nous
débattons sont vastes l'expertise des
représentants d'intérêt est essentielle
puisqu'elle nous permet d'avoir des
échos des territoires et les métiers
toutefois il est important que les
représentants d'intérêts puissent
fournir sur demande des données sur le
financement et les méthodologies des
informations transmises aux personnes
publiques sur lesquelles ces dernières
vont se fonder pour prendre une décision
publique cela doit nous aider à prendre
de meilleur décisions ou en tous les cas
les décisions en connaissance de
cause merci le 220
monsieuronatovski n'est pas donc soutenu
le
666 monsieur Pilet au nom de la
Commission
oui cet amendement fixe les un cadre au
pouvoir de contrôle de la Haute
Autorité la rédaction issue de
l'Assemblée nationale lui confère un
pouvoir de contrôle sur pièce et sur
place dont la portée est assez ambigue
puisquen cas d'entrave à l'action de la
Haute Autorité seul est possible des
poursuites pour l'infraction pénale
d'entrave des délit d'entrave ce qui a
conduit d'ailleurs le Conseil d'État
indiquer dans son avis que la Haute
Autorité ne peut pas imposer de manière
Co son pouvoir de contrôle donc pour
lever toute ambiguïé assurer la
proportionnalité des prérogatives de la
Haute Autorité par rapport aux missions
qui lui sont confiés cet amendement
précise que son pouvoir de contrôle sur
place se limite aux locaux
professionnels des représentants
d'intérêt excluant ainsi le domicile qui
bénéficie d'une protection
constitutionnelle particulière en outre
en cas d'opposition à ce contrôle il
appartiendrait au juges seulement au
juges de statuer pour déterminer si la
demande de communication de vérification
sur place est conforme à la loi à noter
d'ailleurs que cela vient à euh faire
que le régime particulier applicable aux
avocats n'est plus nécessaire car il est
moins protecteur que le régime proposé
ce régime reprend d'ailleurs celui
applicable au défenseurs des droits et
enfin la sanction pénale de vous le
voyez dans l'amendement en cas d'entrave
est limité à une amende la peine
d'emprisonnement est paraissant
disproportionnée en effet je vais
comparer la sanction encourue par un
représentant d'intérêt en cas de
violation de ses obligations est limité
à une amende alors que le délit
d'entrave serait lui puni d'une peine
d'emprisonnement vous verrez que le
montant de l'amand est cependant
augmenté à 30000 € sur le modèle c'est
une question de cohérence sur le modèle
de celle qui est prévu en cas d'entrave
euh euh à l'article 4 du projet de
loi merci alors le 94 rectifié monsieur
adenau
merci madame la Présidente je vais
présenter le 94 et le 93 si vous le
voulez bien puisque dans les deux cas il
s'agit de remplacer la 2e la 3e et la 4e
phrase de l'alinéa 52 par deux phrases
qui vous sont proposées dans les
amendements et il s'agit d'organiser la
protection du secret professionnel des
avocats et les conditions dans lesquel
il pourrai d'abord euh remettre des
informations par la Haute Autorité qui
ne pourra se faire que avec l'accord des
professionnels concernés et ainsi que
l'application du régime spécifique des
perquisition est saisie visé aux
articles 561 à
merci alors le 427 pour monsieur l'abbé
très bien
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues le nouvel
article 188 créé par ce projet de loi
fixe les conditions dans lesquelles la
Haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique va pouvoir se faire
communiquer par leur présentant
d'intérêt toute information au document
nécessaire à l'exercice de sa mission
sans que le secret professionnel puisse
lui être opposé comme le stipule
l'alinéa 51 de l'article 13 du présent
texte en l'état actuel un dispositif
spécifique est tout de même prévu
lorsque ces demandes cette demande
concerne un avocat en effet la demande
de commun ation d'information ou de
documents ne pourra se faire que sur
pièce et non pas sur place et auprès du
Bâtonnier de l'Ordre auprès duquel
l'avocat visé est inscrit il reviendra
au bâtonnier de transmettre à la Haute
Autorité de l'information ou
l'information ou le document demandé cet
amendement tente à modifier ce
dispositif en ce qu'il institue un
nouveau régime de droit de communication
qui n'apporte aucune garantie
supplémentaire au regard de la
nécessaire protection du secrets
professionnel la jurisprudence de donc
du Conseil d'État dans son arrêt du 12
mars 1982 prohibbe tout droit de
communication générale ou absolu portant
atteinte au secret professionnel aussi
le présent amendement propose d'élargir
les garanties non pas seulement aux
avocats mais aussi aux journalistes
médecins huissers de justice et
notairire visés aux articles 561 à 563
du code de la procédure pénale ainsi la
remise des informations de par la Haute
Autorité ne pourra pas se faire sans
l'accord du professionnel concerné en
outre dans l'hypothèse où cette demande
s'opérerait sur place il convient de
prévoir l'application du régime
spécifique des perquisitions et saisies
visé aux articles 561 à 563 du code de
procédure pénale je vous remercie merci
peut-être que vous pouvez présenter le
428 ah non c'est Monsieur des
oui merci madame la Présidente donc bien
sûr que nous souhaitons don que le la
Haute Autorité puisse exercer sa mission
de contrôle vis-à-vis des représentants
d'intérêt mais il y a également dans la
loi la préservation du secret
professionnel et comme cela a été dit
par mon collègue ce n'est pas ce sont
les avocats journalistes médecins
huissiers et notairirees et dans notre
amendement et bien comment all allier
donc la mission de la Haute autorité
pour la transparence avec la PR
réservation du secret professionnel lors
de la communication d'information et
c'est pour ça que nous déposons ces deux
amendements le 667 monsieur Pilet au nom
de la
commission C oui cet amendement accorde
à la Haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique la faculté de rendre
publique une mise en demeure adressée à
un représentant d'intérêt qui ne
respecterait pas les règles
déontologiques qu'elle a fixé qui lui
sont applicables le 350 39 monsieur
Cabanel l'amendement a pour objet de
préciser à la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique
lorsqu'elle avise une personne exerçant
des fonctions publiques qui auraient
répondu favorablement à une
sollicitation effectuée par représentant
d'intérêt peut rendre publiques les
observations adressées à cette personne
il n'y a pas lieu de l'empêcher
d'empêcher la Haute Autorité de de
recourir à cette publicité si elle
l'estime utile au cas d'espèce
l'amendement prévoit par ailleurs la
publicité en cas de réitération du
manquement dans un délé de 5 ans nous
considérons en effet qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de faire porter la seule
responsabilité sur le représentant
d'intérêt nul n'étant censé ignorer la
loi la personne publique qui répond
favorablement à une sollicitation d'un
représentant d'intérêt le fait
nécessairement connaissance de cause et
doit en assumer la responsabilité il
doit dèslors exister une symétrie entre
les obligations et et sanctions pesant
sur les représentants d'intérêts et les
responsables publics en teres de respect
des règles déontologiques dans la mesure
où l'effectivité de ces règles de bonne
conduite repose sur l'adhésion de
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés là
encore cette publicité doit renforcer la
confiance des citoyens en leur
institution en améliorant la
transparence du processus d'élaboration
de la décision
publique
58 l'amendement a pour objet de rétablir
la possibilité pour la haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
de prononcer des sanctions
administratives financières en cas de
manquement par le représentant d'intérêt
à ses obligations déontologiques la
Haute Autorité pourrait ainsi prononcer
une sanction financière d'un montant
maximal de 30000 € pour le représentant
d'intérêt personne physique ou d'un
montant maximal équivalent à 1 % du
chiffre d'affair pour les personnes
morales notre logique est la même celle
de la rapidité et de l'efficacité par le
recours aux sanctions administratives
par ailleurs la sanction serait rendu
publ en cas de réitération du manquement
dans un délai de 5
ans alors avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur sur cette série alors
premièrement l'amendement 3 121 euh cet
amendement est contraire à la position
de la Commission qui a souhaité
instaurer un élément de souplesse en
confiant à la Haute Autorité de le soin
par elle-même de définir les modalités
le rythme de transmission des
information à laquelle sont retenus les
représentants d'intérêt entrant en
communication avec les autorités
gouvernementales et administratives on a
fixé le cadre on laisse à la Haute
Autorité le soin de fixer encore une
fois pour des groupements d'intérêt qui
n'intéresse pas il ne sont pas concernés
par les assemblées euh le soin de fixer
le modalité le rythme de transmission
des information moi ça peut paraître
plus sage de s'en remettre à la Haute
autorité qui va pouvoir ainsi avoir plus
de souplesse que nous dans la loi
moduler et adapter cette durée à l'usage
plutôt que de graver des éléments
intangible dans la loi c'est donc un
avis
défavorable l'amendement 56 16 alors
l'avis était favorable puisque cet
amendement supprime une large partie des
informations à transmettre à la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publi supprime les pouvoirs de contrôle
de cette dernière donc c'est évidemment
un avis
défavorable l'amendement
322 je comprends parfaitement
l'inspiration de cet amendement qui qui
vise à connaître le financement
exhaustif des représentants d'intérêts
cependant l'obligation de transmettre la
liste nominative complète le texte de
votre amendement des financeurs risquent
de devenir problématique lorsqu'il
s'agira de mettre en œuvre par exemple
une fondation ou une grande association
caritative imaginez les restos du cœur
qui doivent envoyer la liste de tous
ceux qui ont donné dans ces condition
cette obligation d'information paraît en
l'état excessive dans son périmètre je
vous demanderai donc de retirer est
entendu encore une fois que la Haute
Autorité fixera les règles pour parvenir
à la transparence maximum du financement
de de ces groupements d'intérêt
l'article l'amendement
323 cet amendement reprend une
disposition qui a été introduite par le
rapporteur de l'Assemblée nationale en
veillant toutefois à retenir un rythme
annuel non pas semestriel de
transmission de ces informations chaque
représentant d'intérêt serait donc tenue
de transmettre des informations
supplémentaires à la Haute Autorité il
me semble que ces précisions ne sont pas
utiles car le texte de la Commission
prévoit en son alinéa 35 que les
représentants d'intérêt devront établir
une présentation de leur activité et que
les modalités de cette présentation
seront fixées encore une fois par la
Haute Autorité par conséquent cet
amendement pourrait compliquer la
rédaction là aussi je sollicite le
retrait bien sûr dans toutes ces
demandes de retrait à défaut c'est des
avis défavorables je me suis expliqué
sur l'amendement 670 qui est un
correction d'erreur matérielle en ce qui
concerne l'amendement numéro
87 alors cet amendement fixe les règles
qui pour partie sont renvoyé par le
texte de la commission à la délibération
de la Haute autorité et qui pour l'autre
relèveront du pouvoir de fixation des
règles reconnues à chaque pouvoir public
constitutionnel le Sénat par exemple
donc avis défavorable ou
retrait amendement
401 alors les amendements 401 et 89 par
des rédaction qui sont
voisines propose de permettre de
solliciter d'un représentant d'
les informations concernant le
financement et la méthodologie des
informations transmises alors il me
semble que ce droit existe sans qu'il
soit d'ailleurs besoin de le reconnaître
si un représentant d'intérêt apporte des
éléments au débat et que ces assertions
ne sont appuyés d'aucune donnée aucun
membre du gouvernement ou
parlementaire ne sera enclin à suivre ce
qui sera plaidé euh dès lors ces
amendements n'apportent pas d'éléments
nouveaux donc pour ces amendements 401
89 j'ai met un avis défavorable ou
plutôt une demande de retrait article
alors l'amendement 666 que j'ai présenté
s'il est adopté fera à mon avis enfin
donnera satisfaction au
rectifiés il est satisfait par
l'amendement que je viens d'évoquer et
il il satisfera également amendement 427
il satisfera également l'amendement
93 et il satisfera l'amendement
et
428 en ce qui concerne l'amendement
359 je pense que ça repose sur un
malentendu le texte qui a été adopté par
la commission reprend sur ce point le
texte qui a été voté par les députés et
il permet à la haute
autorité de rendre publique la mise en
demeure qu'elle a adressé à un
représentant d'intérêt en cas de
violation des règles déontologiques en
revanche si un responsable public
l'autre partie a répondu à une
sollicitation de ce représentant
d'intérêt il a pas forcément commis une
faute donc vous avez deux exemples par
exemple pardon pour l'illustrer un
représentant d'intérêt offre un cadeau à
un responsable public excédent montant
autorisé 150 €. dans ce cas le
responsable public l'a accepté et a
commis comme le représentant d'intérêt
une faute en ne le déclarant pas on est
d'accord mais en revanche si un
représentant d'intérêt qui n'est pas à
jour de la transmission de ces
informations à la Haute Autorité rend
compte un responsable public ce dernier
est pas censé savoir qu'il est pas à
jour dans ses déclarations et dans ce
cas-là il est évident qu' ne faut pas
euh évidemment la Haute Autorité n'aura
pas à publier un
avertissement une enfin en tout cas le
le responsable public pourra pas être
regardé comme fautif donc la diversité
des situations qui peuvent exister entre
euh le responsable représentant
d'intérêt le responsable public ne
permet pas à mon avis dans la loi de
systématiser la publicité des
observations car elles correspondent à
des hypothèses différentes c'est la
raison pour laquelle là aussi je
demanderai un retrait ou à défaut un
avis défavorable madame la Présidente
estje terminé je crois que oui DESC très
bien alors avis du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre sur cette
série merci madame la Présidente alors
sur la plupart de ces amendements le
Gouvernement partage l'avis donné par le
rapporteur qui est un avis défavorable
sauf à ce que ces amendements puissent
être retirés cependant sur le 321 de
Monsieur Marie c'est un avis de sagesse
de la part du gouvernement sur le 576
323 retrait ou défavorable comme le
rapporteur sur l'amendement 670 du
rapporteur qui est très modeste c'est un
amendement très important le
Gouvernement est favorable le 87 ne ne
souriez pas monsieur le rapporteur le 87
rectifié le 401 rectifié le 89 rectifié
le oui là c'est défavorable à défaut
d'un retrait s'agissant du 666 de
Monsieur Pierre je le trouve un peu trop
restrictif et donc je donne à ce stade
un avis défavorable qui emporte
d'ailleurs la même conviction sur les
amendements 94 427 93 rectifié
428 je suis par contre favorable à
l'amendement 667 du rapporteur et à
défaut qu'il soit retiré par Monsieur
Cabanel défavorable sur le 359 et 358 au
compenu des explications données par le
rapporteur
alors nous allons reprendre euh le
321 l'avis de la commission est
défavorable du gouvernement sagesse je
le mets au voix qui est
pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté sur
le
322 en fait je peut-être bien dans
l'ordre ah non 576 voilà avis de la
commission défavorable gouvernement
défavorable qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le 322 là aussi deux
avis défavorables qui est
pour qui contre il s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté alors on est au 323 voilà
défavorable auou retrait il est maintenu
oui alors je le mets au voix qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le
670 alors favorable qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté le
87 rectifié nous avons deux avis
défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le 401 rectifié deux
avis
défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient n'est
pas adopté le 89 rectifié même vote le
666 alors là on a un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté alors le 94 rectifié tombe le 427
également aussi le
428 et nous arrivons au
avec un avis favorable du gouvernement
qui est
pour qui est contre il s'abstient il est
adopté le 359 est
maintenu bon donc je le mets au voix
avec avis défavorable qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté même vote pour le
358 et nous arrivons à l'amendement 650
présenté par le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci madame la Présidente nous
passons un autre type de de débat qui
est strictement juridique il y a pas là
non plus de désaccord sur le
fond le la commission vous me dites si
je me trompe monsieur le rapporteur
préfère renvoyer à une disposition
réglementaire la fixation des
obligations les règles déontologiques
que les représentants d'intérêts devront
respecter dans leur rapport avec les
autorités gouvernementale et
administrative alors que nous
considérons que l'article 34 de la
Constitution ne permet pas de revoyer
ses dispositions à un décret c'est ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon juridique
une incompétence négative du
législateur je vous rappelle une
décision du Conseil d'État de du 18
juillet 2008 qui dit je cite lorsque la
définition des obligations auquel est
soumis l'exercice d'une activité c'est
bien le cas relève du législateur en
application de l'article 34 de la
Constitution il n'appartient qu'à la loi
de fixer les sanctions administrativ
dont la méconnaissance de ces
obligations peut-être assortie et en
particulier déterminer tant les
sanctions encourues que les éléments
constitutifs des infractions que ces
sanctions ont pour objet de réprimer
c'est donc pour rendre ce texte
irréprochable du point de vue
constitutionnel
que je vous propose cet amendement merci
al avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur oui la Commission a souhaité
confier à la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique la
détermination des règles déontologiques
qui sont applicables au représentants
d'intérêts dans leur relation avec les
autorités gouvernementales et
administratives pour les assemblées ces
règles seraient fixé par les bureaux ce
choix est évidemment un gage de
souplesse car l'expérience des
assemblées de l'approuver ces règles
doivent être régulièrement adaptées or
si je prends l'amendement du
Gouvernement je constate que la loi
viendrait réglementer l'usage des logos
et des entêtes ce qui me semble assez
éloigné de sa vocation première par cet
amendement c'est le point plus important
le gouvernement soulève le risque de
l'incompétence négative en indiquant que
la violation de ces règles pourra
entraîner des sanctions et que ces
sanctions àorie pénale doivent reposer
sur la violation de règles définies par
la loi alors je suis
interrogé sur ce point et j'ai
évidemment interrogé des personnes plus
spécial que moi mais l'analyse de la
jurisprudence constitutionnelle m'a
conduit à écarter ce risque en prenant
l'exemple des décisions rendues par la
Cour de cassation en novembre 2011 sur
plusieurs délits relatifs à la probité
le Conseil constitutionnel déduit du
principe de l'égalité des délits et des
peine les principes de précision et de
prévisibilité de la loi pénale dont elle
permet de déterminer le champ
d'application pour le citoyen je
prendrai l'exemple du délit de
favoritisme qui est prévu à l'article
413 144 du code pénal qui SAN le fait de
procurer ou de tenter de procurer un
avantage en violant je cite les
dispositions législatives et
réglementair ayant pour objet de
garantir la liberté d'accès et l'égalité
des candidats dans les marchés publics
et les délégations de servicees publics
cette infraction sanctionne la violation
de règles qui ne sont pas directement
prévu par la loi une QPC était soulevée
sur le même grief contre cette
infraction et la Cour de cassation l'a
pourtant jugé conforme à la Constitution
car elle réprime dit la cour des
cassations en terme suffisamment clair
et précis pour exclure l'arbitraire dans
le cas présent le périmètre des règles
que la Haute Autorité devra fixer est
limitativement énuméré dans la loi du 11
octobre 2014 ces catégories de règles
sont précises et la sanction pénale ne
pourrait s'appliquer qu'à une catégorie
identifiée de personnes c'est les
représentants d'intérêts par conséquent
le risque constitutionnel qui existe
toujours me paraît néanmoins minime
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai le
regret de donner un avis défavorable à
l'amendement 650 du gouvernement très
bien ben alors je vais mettre au voix
cet amendement qui a reçu du
gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstien il n'est pas adopté
le suivant le 649 toujours le
gouvernement monsieur ministre
oui madame la Président je serai bref
parce que c'est un débat qui a déjà
parcouru ne rant est-ce qu'il faut
donner la possibilité de prononcer une
sanction administrative c'est vrai en
l'occurrence pour la Haute Autorité
aujourd'hui c'était vrai sagissant de
l'agence hier nous pensons nécessaire
pour des raisons d'efficacité de
rapidité que ces autorités
administrative puisse disposer de cette
capacité de sanction administrative euh
alors que vous-même vous souhaitez
confier l'ensemble de ces pouvoirs
directement et exclusivement à
l'autorité judiciaire dans le cadre de
poursuite pénale donc le gouvernement
est logique avec lui-même et maintient
cette volonté d'être efficace dans le
respect des grands principes qui
régissent à la fois la défense la
transparence le contradictoire qui sont
nécessaires à la régularité de ces
procédures monsieur le rapporteur pour
l'avis de la commission mon ministre a
été bref effectivement c'est un débat
qu'on a déjà eu on connaît les positions
de de chacun la Commission veut rester
fidèle à la sienne alors je vous
rappelle que la Haute Autorité ne
dispose actuellement d'aucun pouvoir de
sanction et en cas de manquement aux
obligations déclaratives déclaration
d'intérêt le cas des échéants d'activité
ainsi que de déclaration de situation
patrimoniale la Haute Autorité ne peut
saisir peut que saisir le parquet pour
engager des poursuites pénales sur le
fondement d'infraction pénale la
Commission n'a pas souhaiter remettre en
cause cet équilibre trouvé lors de la
création de l'autorité donc on ne va
paser jusqu'à lui donner des sanction
qu'elle n'a jamais eu pour ses missions
actuelles en résumé le
pouvoir
de la Haute Autorité s'arrêtera jusqu'on
prononcer de la mise en demeure qu'elle
pourrait avec l'amendement proposé par
la Commission rendre publique au au-delà
la répression c'est l'autorité
judiciaire donc c'est un avis
défavorable à l'amendement du
Gouvernement très bien ben je vais
mettre au voix cette
oui monsieur
mard vous avez la
paroleieur merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre effectivement je ne
peux pas manquer
l'occasion de reparler des autorités
administratives indépendantes donc de la
Haute Autorité transparence et nous
avons suffisamment travaillé sur dans ce
domaine au Sénat pour suivre la av de la
commission qui me paraît
particulièrement judicieux à force de
donner aux autorités administratives
indépendante des pouvoirs de sanction
alors que jusqu'ici d'ailleurs la Haute
Autorité transparence lorsqu'elle
constatait certains fait devait
transmettre à l'autorité judiciaire au
parquet là on ouvre si on suivait le
gouvernement on ouvrirait une fois de
plus une brèche qui est à mon avis tout
à fait regrettable et je crois que
l'avis de la commission est
particulièrement pertinent à moins que
nous ne soyons définitivement sous le
contrôle de ces autorités administrative
indépendante chè à la haute fonction
publique monsieur
Vassel madame la Présidente je voudrais
profiter de cet amendement du
Gouvernement pour faire remarquer un peu
dans la ligne de ce que vient d'exprimer
notre collègue monsieur mard c'est qu'il
est prévu à l'alinéa 53 qui est passé
que la Haute Autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique protège
la confidentialité des informations et
documents auxquels elle a accès pour
l'exercice de cette mission hors ceux
dont la publication est prévue au
présent article très bien on donne un
pouvoir de sanction à la Haute Autorité
mais quelles sanctions pourront être
appliqué à la Haute autorité qui ne
respecterait pas la confidentialité je
n'ai vu aucun alinéat aucun article de
la loi qui prévoirait des sanctions à
l'encontre de la Haute autorité et qui
ne respecteraiit pas la
confidentialité sauf si monsieur le
rapporteur peut m'éclairer sur ce point
dans une autre disposition peut-être du
texte un peu plus loin mais je pense que
si on veut un équilibre entre l'un et
l'autre je crois que les sanctions la
Haute Autorité elle doit pas être placée
en dehors de toute sanction elle doit
elle-même respecter la confidentialité
donc j'aimerais bien être éclairé sur ce
point
bien
alors il n'y a pas d'autre prise de
parole donc je vais mettre au voix cette
ah Monsieur Doliger
oui ça va être très court mais je
voudrais dire que je soutiens 100 % les
deux interventions qui viennent d'être
faites plus ça va plus on donne de
pouvoir au autorités il y en a un
certain nombre qui existe maintenant qu'
tous les pouvoirs et qui sont
incontrôlables c'est ça devient
totalement insupportable alors c'est
vrai pour le Défenseur des droits parce
qu'il a des limites hein on peut pas
aller jusqu'à un certain point contrôler
ce qu'il fait c'est vrai maintenant pour
la haute autorité qui va avoir des
pouvoirs quasiment illimité à chaque
fois que nous intervenons sur ces sujets
là on en met un peu plus bon et et en
final on aura plus aucune capacité de
contrôler qui que ce soit alors moi
j'aimerais bien qu'effectivement suite à
l'intervention de nos collègues et de
notre collègue Vassel qu'on puisse avoir
quelques informations complémentaires ou
quelques réponses à ces Inter
merci et bien
sans intervention je vais mettre au voix
cet amendement du gouvernement qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 668 monsieur Pilet
la date d'entrée en vigueur des règles
applicables aux autorités
gouvernementales et administratives on
fixe une date du butoire au 1er janvier
2017 merci avis du
Gouvernement est
favorable bien je le mets au voix qui
est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté je mets au voix l'article 13
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté voilà pour les débats des
sénateurs notamment autour de l'article
13 qui porte sur les relations entre les
lobbyes et les pouvoirs publics les
sénateurs ont débattu depuis lundi des
points de la loin sapin 2 qui pent sur
la lutte contre la corruption et sur la
transparence noté qu'aujourd'hui bien
ils vont aborder le P consacré à la
modernisation de la vie économique avec
le min ministre Emmanuel Macron vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 16h30 avec Delphine Girard et Sénat
360 très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires